okay so we're continuing to talk about
testing and Donald Trump has now
confirmed that he was not kidding when
he said slow down coronavirus testing
the White House has been tripping all
over itself for days to say Trump was
just joking
Trump was then asked were you joking and
he said I don't kid and yet the White
House just keeps saying oh he's kidding
he's kidding
this is borderline criminal and it's
definitely murderous and I want to be
sure that you have all of the facts to
understand this story so I'm going
instead of going through this story
however else I might do it I'm going to
go through the story chronologically for
you okay so the start of the story is
the United States failed on coronavirus
testing from day one the u.s. and South
Korea got our first cases at the same
time within hours of each other we
didn't develop a test quickly we didn't
roll out a test quickly we didn't
contact trace an isolate South Korea did
they dominated the virus we are leading
in cases and deaths so that's like the
the quick summary that gets us to
Saturday Saturday at his Corona rally in
Tulsa Oklahoma Trump admitted for the
first time I told them to do less
testing in order to find fewer cases
this is from Saturday testify when you
do testing to that extent you're gonna
find more people you're gonna find more
cases so I said to my people slow the
testing down please they test and they
test we had test the people don't know
what's going on we got this we got
another one over here so this is of
course completely outrageous it's a
president admitting that for political
reasons he asked for something that
leads to more death the White House
reaction was he was just kidding
spokespeople said it was just a joke
representatives said it was sarcasm
so then on Monday Jo st. George
interviews Trump and asks him did you
order coronavirus testing to be slowed
down Trump doesn't really answer the
question but he does say a lot of words
take a look
on Saturday night you said that you told
your staff to slow the testing down to
improve the numbers does that mean
someone watching this right now on their
local news is not going to get a test
because you asked we do more testing
than any country in the world by far
twenty five million tests other
countries do 1 million every time you do
a test as you do more tests it shows
more and more cases so we're so far
advanced both in terms of the quality
and the amount and we're doing all these
tests and it shows cases if other
countries aren't doing or if we did slow
it down we wouldn't show nearly as many
cases so here Trump doesn't deny that he
asked for less testing he simply says if
we did less testing we'd have fewer
cases and again reporters ask the White
House and the Trump campaign
did he really order testing to be slowed
down because he didn't deny it he was
given the chance by Joe st. George to
deny it and he did not deny it and the
White House again says it's a joke the
campaign says he was kidding etc etc so
finally yesterday Donald Trump is asked
straight-up were you kidding because
people are saying you were kidding were
you kidding and Trump says I don't kid
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't kid let me just tell you let me
make it clear we have got the greatest
testing program anywhere in the world so
Trump goes into the same talking point
again but the key phrase is I don't kid
he was not kidding
when he asked for testing to be slowed
down he was not kidding when he said
that he asked for testing to be slowed
down are they also going to say that him
saying he doesn't kid was a form of
kidding like what's left at this point
from this crumbled attempted defense of
Donald Trump he's given chance after
chance he's presented with opportunity
after opportunity to improve his answer
like it's a do-over in a sense and he
just restates what he said on Saturday
night he could clarify oh well you know
why I meant this other thing he doesn't
change it at all because it's the truth
it's like being allowed to retake a test
after you're given all the answers and
you still put down all the same wrong
answers from when you first took the
test I got an email saying David is this
is this a confession to negligent
homicide
Trump is admitting that he asked for
something to be done which he thought
would be good politically which leads to
more deaths I mean maybe I just don't
even think this is the right direction
to go like Trump is not going to be held
criminally liable in any way here we
essentially have you know I mean it's
kind of depressing but for for a couple
years now I've been saying November 3rd
2020 is when we will have the
opportunity to give him a consequence
we're talking about him like he's a
little boy who's misbehaved because
essentially that's how he behaves the it
wasn't going to be the Russia
investigation it wasn't going to be
impeachment it's not going to be removal
under the 25th amendment by his cabinet
for being unfit the opportunity for a
consequence is November 3rd and all of
these disasters and tragedies are valid
reasons to remove him and hopefully we
will do it because it's really
the only opportunity that we have real
quick I want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon who have done
something awesome they've taken all of
our favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry they taste great
they're crunchy they're sweet like you
would expect this type of cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one Bowl has only three net
carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free gluten-free grain free soy
free once our team tried magic spoon for
the first time we actually ended up
emailing magic spoon back and saying can
you send us more boxes send more samples
they've been a big hit with David Pakman
show staffers and magic spoon knows how
delicious their cereal is because if you
don't like it they'll refund all of your
money no questions asked and you'll get
free shipping when you go to magic spoon
dot-com slash Pakman and use the code
Pakman that's PA que ma N